I just want to justify for everyone
watching I'm very tired I'm not high
he's not I'm just not depressed
Oh
[Laughter]
ostentatious start that's on the right
word that star was ostentatious man
we're gonna start like porn star I don't
agree with this thing that's happening I
lack when you do when you were so
excited thanks Jack Derek Jerry
Derek yeah that one was pretty obvious
is uh Derek's brother Jarek don't shoot
the watermelons brother Derek um so mark
with something hilarious
oh shut up
no I'm not not a [ __ ] this fridge is
too cool I wanna be one of these there
are several there are several of them
for future reference oh hey is this mark
know exactly what do you think we're
both downstairs
both melons yeah sure I'm sure that you
are I'm sure that's the time table
you've seen you eat on buns so everyone
says something different
alt f4
wait no that's I can see I could see I
was that but that's where I freaked up I
was that how much help do you have me
okay between these two things I won hell
I don't want to say how much health I
have that give away what I am he's
either got a lot or a little blob it's
just one or all of it I don't know man I
remember now I'm awful at this game
[Laughter]
there's a proper way out of place and I
don't get it everyone's laughing at me
yeah but that's what makes what happened
these vending machines to push these
vending machines around is that I'm
responsible for finding mark thanks jack
I know I tried real hard after I failed
so much pretty good you gotta qualify it
[Laughter]
[Music]
there we go
I don't want my return to profit to be
around look man Marcus so high before
this I can't believe it I just woke up
alright we
what the bacteria yeah I didn't Utley
[Laughter]
[Music]
knocked over a chair oh oh definitely
not definitely not there
oh it was probably barn it wasn't really
honest it was probably mark I think you
should interrogate all the chairs and
shoot them if they don't give you the
answer you want
give you I'll give you I'll give you uh
I'll give you a present if you find the
right chair if you stop and point at
every chair and eventually you point at
me I will undo my rotation lock and I
will shimmy okay I'll play this game
Jack I'll be the fool they think all the
chairs are in the kitchen you're on the
wrong floor blue which all the chairs
are blue probably probably the benches
are made of wood and not blue which is
an important fact but I am blue and all
the chairs are blue he's got a pawn wait
blue wait a minute I know what he is
[Music]
on to you what gets the way like what
gives - I thought the soda cans were all
borked
I suspected it with my obvious brain
they'll shoot me if you point at me but
you don't shoot me I'll shimmy I don't
want to play this game 50 seconds left
mark I have to make it interesting
something you're taxing my tired mind
alright you stay down right these things
wait they already know what you say wait
we didn't hear we were too busy being
idiots do it you can do it Bob
well he said you were a cat already yeah
just go upstairs tech no I'm upstairs
actually that's a terrible flu isn't it
never mind I'm stupid wait wait wait why
is it terrible clear explain it explain
please explain mistakes were made
mistakes were made
Bob why whatever I'm still good I'm
changed objects but I'm still blue so
how about that wait was there already
been tears there were three bins before
huh wait a minute Oh
oh damn your team I understand your
misdirecting lies Yeah right when you're
like oh I got a chair on the first
floors like yeah you know I tell you
some truth every time I speak it's just
not helpful or in you know correctly
leading yeah come on I'm stuck I spawned
stuck okay good all right Bob wait Bob
you're now a permanent sentry on the
bottom floor so you all right yeah so
this is my role now is just go search
wait I'll watch this I see down the
hallway too so I'll watch this and you
go look we're down floors as a prop
you can't yeah that one [ __ ] moves
I'm gonna blast you anyone
Bob you might want to pay a little more
attention down here but I couldn't hit
him down the hallway even though I swear
to God I was looking right at him I saw
you I was just shooting at you sorry
yeah I just wanted to I can't say that
mark you want to kill Jack he's
downstairs in the last room on the left
in the hallway wait or he's just in the
hallway and I can't see him from the
table but he went out there and he kept
trying to get in the room didn't fit you
killed him I thought yeah oh thank 9 you
can stop lying now for the love of God
tell the truth I didn't kill you I was
really frustrated you shot me right
because
go into the rooms are you at Marik I'm
nowhere and also know you're okay I
thought you were the thing yeah wait
gosh fix her god damn it what start to
your internet what's wrong I'm getting a
lot of lag man yeah and you sound like a
robot really everything's fine online he
sounds good to me you guys are stupid
doesn't mean everything's fine to me
I have no idea look at this little [ __ ]
of what huh where is he sobbing in the
bathrooms then a surprisingly big little
[ __ ] yeah wait what he's a big literate
little [ __ ] in your actions but not in
your thanks I think I feel insulted but
I will take it as a compliment I thought
maybe you meant something by that but
you didn't
[Laughter]
we were riskier on vom why am I so laggy
I don't understand the [ __ ] Oh Oh God
I believe you Oh God
oh no I need an adult okay fantastic
oh god Bob you might notice some things
when you go upstairs I know
oh darn you're [ __ ] bugged
[Laughter]
such a goddamn fool nothing extra moving
before what the hell happened okay I
don't want well sure you can weird is
happening in here
it's just double trashcan day
[Applause]
Oh No well no no no come on yeah
computer why why frame rates like that's
pretty impressive
[Laughter]
eat some chocolate you guys do whatever
you want a good spot you can't take your
eyes off really I do I do
what is that theory that there weren't
as many felons on shelves before
[Music]